like I said over till the end now
composit solids we put the composite
sold in this topic or great weather here
boy
now what I'd like you to do is just put
like your finger or your pen in your
current page way right and they just
turn back turn back to where we did
surface area of focus or solar do you
remember what I told you at the
beginning of that lesson and I hope you
have some things written down what's
there
thank you very much I said come to the
solids they come in no pun intended all
shapes and sizes so therefore there's no
formula you don't treat all the same but
there are principles that work for all
of them so the first thing I wonder is
go look at those three prints will just
cost your eye over them from memory I
think it's you're going to toss up your
diagrams yeah absolutely search within
label what the places are you looking at
and lastly yeah make sure you if you can
hold 12 this one and this to tell me
what you're doing okay come back to
where you got this panel today spinning
the first thing I want to say about
volumes and compliment salat is
everything from the surface area of cups
of solids everything else still applies
you should still draw a diagram
you should still label it carefully and
when you're doing the final answer
you should still identify all the
components I suppose the only difference
is because we're doing volume not the
surface area volume is not interested in
faces right boys interested in what kind
of shapes what kind of blocks make up
this thing but the idea is the same so
number one everything you like before
let's use those principles again but I'm
gonna include two extra little dot
points underneath the to enter points
are there are two ways you can make a
compass two solid you can take a
familiar shape like this and if you like
you can sort of tack something on to
your side so I could say let's say put a
pyramid on top of here
okay so that's one way to make a
composite solvent and you can see you do
the cube then you do the pyramid and you
would combine them no big deal but
that's not the only way to make a
composite solid but most could I do it
yeah thank you very much
instead of padding a solid I could like
punch a hole in it something like this
here's my cube and I could say drill a
cylindrical hole right through the
middle okay so you can either do things
by addition or subtraction or if they
won't be really sleepy some combination
of both okay so my tip is look carefully
when you've got your concept solid is it
composed of adding shapes together is it
addition or volume or is it subtraction
okay so that's the first thing you need
to look at because obviously you can
work these two things out their numbers
they give me the same but here you'll
add the volume here you subtract okay
and you've got to know which one you're
subtracting from which big one versus
small there's the second principle one
adult
secondly look at the question under this
idea of volume of compass of solids is a
very very closely related idea to volume
that's not quite funny it's about well
if I got a bottle of milk or a can I
wouldn't say Oh bigger he's uh 250 cubic
centimeters of milk he wouldn't describe
a liquid like that instead of saying all
the reason you would say what measure
would you use you would say capacity so
capacity is measured in mills
liters kilo liters that's the kind of
unit of measure now I always just be
quite confused about what's the
difference okay so let me point out the
difference in two ways number one the
units so the unity
for example we looked at this just
enough so you could have cubic
centimeters or you could have cubic
meters or if you have something really
big
you could have cubic kilometers so
that's how we measure volume alternately
as I was just mentioning we measure
capacity in things like meals please
notice the capital health liters or you
can just keep on going up okay by the
way
Mills does anyone know what Mills in
store for its struggle of mili liters
right in the milling like millimeter
it's one thousand right so from here to
here to here to here if you can't
remember each time you go up a level
you're multiplied by a thousand and
that's what they creating on your wave
fitness okay also don't because we tend
to use water in very large quantities
like we measure it like a dam even which
is the small body of water it's pretty
big when you go from middles all the way
up to make your liters which is times
1000 times 1000 times a thousand please
know either when you write an answer or
when you read it it began for mega
litres little add in four minutes that's
easy to remember because the middle M is
a little measure and the big game is a
big measure now there's one more thing I
want to say it's not just the unit's
right they're actually measuring
different kinds of things and I'll try
and explain what I mean follow you in
any color
volume is about how much space does an
object it's like a compass and solid how
much space does it take up doesn't
okay so that's like I can't what have
five you have to measure to get this
capacity is a little bit different and
this prefix Kappa not really performing
us in this context is what describes to
you what the difference is capacity is
this is the question asked by volunteer
the question asked by capacity is how
much are you capable Carrie okay let me
say that again volumes about how much
space does an object to take up whereas
capacity is how much stuff is it capable
like a container capable capacity of
holding so really it's kind of the
difference between the inside and the
outside now just to make things simple
in most cases we don't ask you to
distinguish between the inside and
outside we're kind of pictured these
arms solids as having perfectly thin
walls so the outside is the same as the
inside so you can go back and forth
between these does anyone know how do
you convert between volume and capacity
yeah
perfect so put this in a nice feed box
over life inside your book reader right
inside your space there if you've worked
in how many cubic centimetres are in an
object that's how many mails there are
simple you can use this to convert to
all the rest for instance if I wanted
not one mil but one liter over that
thing from here to here it's gotten a
thousand times bigger
so therefore this also has to get a
downtime video so this is 1,000 could be
ten minutes okay
you have to be a little bit careful if
you do say something like this a cute
made-up mmm here's a meet-up right this
is a meter so if I said stood this way
you see that green light so that's how
wide my box is this is how high my box
is and then to make it a cubic meter I
have to come out like this as well does
that make sense this is a big box right
it's that wide that pie and this is how
far out of college so this is a lot of
meters right can we work out how many
hmm I need a bit more space I hope
you've got a bit of space underneath way
you've written a key let's do this
the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna turn it into cubic centimeters so
I notice just watch this 1 meter cubed
is actually 1 meter times 1 meter times
1 meter that's what I was doing with
this to remember like 1 1 1 yeah how
many centimeters is made up 100
but notice just like the whole meter
gets cubed the whole 100 centimeters
also gets cue so a hundred times 100
times 100 how many zeros six that's a
million yeah so now I'm ready to do my
conversion based on my first line over
there that is 1 million Mills
so now I can convert to liters if I want
to how many liters it's exactly a
thousand liters which means that by
coincidence
it is exactly 1 kilo liter that's a lot
of three-member 3 liter milk cartons
okay but that's because like I said this
thing is surprisingly beef we don't
usually think in cubic minutes so let's
review everything he knew about drawing
diagrams labeling clearly setting out
your working properly do that again when
you're doing volumes in fact in some
ways even more so secondly be careful
are you adding shapes together or are
you taking them away and lastly just pay
attention what are they actually asking
for if they are asking for capacity just
like I have work out your volume first
and then do a conversion like this and
you won't go wrong okay